[Music]
I need some advice dude if it's about a
ghost look I was at the supermarket
already and then turn a corner
[Music]
ronaldo
that's the horrible underwear you
wear the shop is here where they sell
tomatoes
[Music]
playing a little by little
you are dark in lightning I
love soccer and I am very proud of you
tati thank you
[Music]
I am not going to look for the pestilence what is
the strategy to all those who want to
vote for me I am going to offer you one
of these pizzas  individual little ones
and what if you join some
gray and teresa
already take great care because this
town nothing is what it seems
[Music]
for the moods
at home
[Music]
thank you for inviting me to dinner it is very
important to me that time passes
quality with my husband I am preparing
his favorite comedy office
[Music]